c'est bizarre exténué en disent long
depuis que cette place au coeur de la
ville de vinh hitia'a été frappées dans
la matinée de jeudi les travaux n'ont
pas cessé les corps des nombreuses
victimes ont été évacuées il faut
maintenant débarrassé la cinquantaine de
carcasses de voiture était garée dans un
parking qui n'existe plus
il faut nettoyer les gravats
[Musique]
il faut aussi récolter des indices et
comment celle enquête
[Musique]
juste à côté de l'un des points d'impact
d'après nos premières observations je
perds missiles en catégorie cadets
les missiles de croisière calibre lancé
depuis des navires ou des sous marins en
mer noire sont souvent utilisés par la
russie pour bombarder l'ukraine les
procureurs sont comme presque tout le
monde avait ni de sya visiblement secoué
c'est une place une place il y a
toujours dû toujours beaucoup de monde
peut-être qu'il y avait des soldats qui
faisait leur propre affaire mais
l'écrasante majorité des victimes sont
des civils
des victimes dont alexandre a failli
faire partie
je me suis garé pour aller un
distributeur
j'ai été posée à l'argent
je suis retourné à
six secondes plus tard je serai mort
parce qu'à peine je suis entré dans la
voiture le missile a frappé
donc pendant ces 10 secondes ma voiture
m'a sauvé la vie regardez ici un bout de
ma soeur m'a montré les jours en terre d
810 ont le mérite la cause mais
qu'est-ce qui va pas dans votre quête
sérieusement je parle le russe je dis à
personne n'a de problème avec ça
le quartier est quadrillée c'est la
première fois depuis le début de
l'invasion russe qu'une ville
ukrainienne située aussi loin des lignes
de front et est frappé de cette manière
en son centre une manière pour l'armée
russe de rappeler à toute la population
ukrainienne que personne n'est à l'abri